Tensions between the US and
China are on high this morning
after a blunt meeting between
the two nation's top diplomats, the first
since the US shot down
a suspected Chinese spy balloon earlier
this month
and a quote,
very direct and candid
meeting on the sidelines
of the Munich Security Conference.
Secretary of State
Antony Blinken told
his counterpart Wang Yi
the balloon was an unacceptable violation
of U.S. sovereignty.
That must never occur again.
The State Department said.
A senior official said
that Blinken also criticized China
for not engaging in military
to military dialog over
the incident, when Chinese
military officials, quote,
refused to pick up the phone
and underline
a concern raised in earlier
remarks by the vice
president, Lincoln warned China
there would be consequences
if they provide military aid to Russia.
In its war against Ukraine.
The informal meeting came hours
after China's
top diplomat criticized
the US response to the balloon.
In a speech to the leaders
attending the conference,
including a bipartisan group of top U.S.
lawmakers.
And joining me now
from the Munich Security Conference,
chairman of the House Foreign Affairs
Committee, Michael McCaul, and chairman
of the House Intelligence
Committee, Mike Turner.
Thank you both for coming on
Thank you, panel.
So, Congressman McCaul,
I want to start with you here.
The US-China relationship is a key
topic of discussion at the Munich summit,
where you are
China's foreign minister
addressed the gathering
and mocked the U.S.
response to the Chinese surveillance
balloon, calling it,
quote, absurd
and hysterical and an effort
to, quote, divert attention
from its domestic problems.
What is your response to him?
Well,
you know,
I had a conversation with the secretary's
team.
I would send a very stark, stern
warning to him
that we will not tolerate a spy
born in this,
you know, committing espionage
over the United States again.
And I know there's
talk of a private meeting,
but this is a bit of a shot
across the bow at this conference.
And I know Blinken spoke as well.
This is a time
when our relations have never been more
The tension is very high right now,
I should say.
And I think the spy balloon
was so embarrassing, going over three
major military installations
with nuclear warheads.
The idea it could capture imagery
and send it back
to Beijing to another ship
cause a lot of damage
to our national security.
But also
political damage
in the sense that Americans saw this
with the naked eye
and it was flying so low to the ground.
And of course, the administration
has countered
that it prevented the balloon
from being able to gather information
on sensitive U.S.
sites and it learn valuable information
from studying it.
And they ultimately shot it down.
Secretary Blinken's trip to China
was delayed, canceled and China's
actions were condemned.
But President Biden
this week stressed that the US
is not seeking a new Cold War with China
and said he plans to speak with President
Xi at some point.
You just heard there,
Congressman Turner
from Congressman McCaul, about just how
how the tensions are right now
between the US and China,
how bad the relations are.
What should his message be to.
And do you think that Biden is right
to try to lower the temperature
with China in the wake of this incident?
Well, remember, the
balloon was an escalation
and it was not forwarded
from its mission.
It flew over our missile defense
sites, our nuclear weapons sites,
and then it wasn't taken out of the game
until the game was over. In the Atlantic.
The reality is,
is that the administration
admitted that
after it had shot down the balloon
that it should have been more proactive
in the three subsequent
shoot downs
that it did
of what appears to be harmless
objects over North America.
So the administration does have a shift
that it needs to take
in taking
all of this
a lot more serious
now, being more forward
also with the American public
and with China
as to what we're facing
and what their espionage plans were.
But, you know, here, I do think that
there is an opportunity
to get back to a normal dialog
with China.
No one, of course, wants a Cold War,
but that isn't the issue.
What we want is a China
that is not going to be
an aggressor state
that's not going to be building up
its military
and threatening the United States
and certainly not
not making the negative comments
that it's making instead of
just openly apologizing
for sending a spy balloon
over our most sensitive military sites.
So as we just heard, you both have been
critical of President Biden's
response to China here at home.
But politics
traditionally stops at the water's edge.
Are you and the Biden administration
on the same page
and presenting a united message
to the world
when it comes to countering China,
where you are right now in Munich?
Congressman McCaul, first to you.
Yeah, I think we
have a
unique opportunity
to be bipartisan
on this issue of,
you know, national security
against one of the greatest threats to
to this country in the world
for that matter.
And I think,
you know, the fact
that a select committee was
voted on by a large majority
of Democrats.
So when we talk about particularly export
controls, this balloon,
by the way,
had a lot of American parts in it.
We know that the hypersonic missile
that went around
the world
with precision
was built on the backbone
of American technology.
So there's a lot of discussion here
at this summit about how can we
you know,
they steal a lot of this from us,
but we don't have to sell them
the very technology
they can put in their advanced weapons
systems
to then turn against either
Taiwan and the Pacific
or eventually possibly
the United States of America.
I think there's great bipartisanship
on this issue,
by the way, as well as Ukraine.
I think our delegation
has been very unified
in our support for Ukraine
and putting everything we can
from a weapons
perspective in the Ukraine
so they can defeat the Russians.
All right.
Let's turn to Ukraine.
As you mentioned, Congressman McCaul,
it is a big talker there at the summit.
I remember last year
everyone was talking about Russia
getting ready to invade.
Now, it's been nearly a year.
And nearly a dozen members in your party
have introduced
a so-called
Ukraine fatigue resolution to end U.S.
support for Ukraine.
And a new poll is showing support
among Americans for arming
Ukraine is dropping.
How concerned,
Congressman McCall are foreign leaders?
You're speaking
to that American support
for Ukraine, particularly
within your own party, is weakening
Well, I know that Bill
had about ten co-sponsors out of 435
members of Congress.
I would say that
support is still very strong.
And this delegation is bipartisan,
very strong support for Ukraine.
I think we're you're seeing a split
from the administration, though.
And I have to say, well,
this is bipartisan as well.
Is that for the past year,
we've been very slow
in getting these weapons
in in the name of being too provocative,
whether it be stingers, jab ones, these
short range artillery,
no longer range artillery attack.
And they can take out the Iranian drones
in Crimea and also aviation like F-16.
If we put this stuff in
from the very beginning of this conflict,
a year from now
may have been very different
as we look
at the anniversary on February 24th.
The longer they drag this out
they play into Putin's hands.
He wants this
to be a long, protracted war
because he knows that potentially
he'll lose.
We could lose the will
of the American people.
And therefore the Congress.
And we're seeing the same dynamic
in the European Parliament's
strong support now.
But they're worried that if this doesn't
end with the resolution you know, sooner
rather than later,
this will be an issue for us.
Yeah, and you mentioned the need
for Ukraine to have more weapons to fight
Russia, a
bipartisan group in Congress,
including some members
on your own committee,
wrote to President Biden
urging him to give Ukraine F-16
fighter jets.
You said the US
should give Ukraine, quote,
everything they need to win this thing.
Congressman McCaul,
do you believe the administration
is considering taking that step
You know, I hope so.
The attack himself
had been on the table for months
and they have sent those in.
And the same delivery applies to attack.
And those are the high MOIS.
But, you know, the fact is,
the longer they wait,
the longer this
this conflict will prevail.
I honestly, every top military expert
I talked to at this conference
agreed with what I was saying.
And I think, you know, Mike Turner,
that we need to throw
everything we can into this fight
so that they can win.
And once he's going to tell us
that soon as well,
he had a speech here at the conference
saying the same thing.
And I think the momentum is building
for this to happen.
Congressman Turner, to you,
you're
also on the Armed Services Committee.
We should note, according to Politico,
the top Democrat on that committee,
Representative Adam Smith, said
at the Munich Security Conference, quote,
There's more of a consensus
that there
that people realize that Ukraine
is not going to militarily retake Crimea.
I'm wondering if you
agree with that assessment.
No statements
like that, Pamela, are not helpful.
And, you know,
we're at an international conference.
You mentioned Republicans.
There are 20 Democrats
that sent a letter to Biden
saying that
we should have immediate negotiations
and bring an end to this war.
Putin,
we talked in that letter
and you would agree there is a difference
between you can't reach resolution
and withdraw but you can't.
Pamela, you can't retract
a letter from Putin hearing it
so it doesn't have any effect when.
28 members
letter was about a letter resolution
for Democrats not withdrawing the
who write
who are Democrats
and write a letter to the president.
Well, by the way, Pamela,
none of the conversations
that we're having here are the kind
that you're asking us questions of.
No.
One here is the debate
because more about the conversation
only when we're in this interview.
All want instead of you has people
talking about Republicans or Democrats.
What they've asked is,
is there bipartisan support?
In fact,
I just did a panel with Director Burns
indicating our full bipartisan support
on the intelligence
side, on the armed services side
for full support for Ukraine.
You have a handful on both sides,
both sides, Pamela,
who have have been cautious
or who have said that they don't support
or they want support to come to an end
That's not the over 400.
You know,
there are four
35 members of Congress are probably 400.
Therefore, continuing this direction
in this path.